info ou intox c'est avec antoine fenaux
bonjour antoine bonjour raphaël et 2,1
fox au menu ce soir autour des hommes et
des femmes politiques on commence
d'abord à bruxelles absolument avec une
info que ce qui vous allez le voir
touche la présidente de la commission
européenne poursuit la vendeurs les
notamment avec ses ses tweets ces
exemples de tweets que vous allez voir
ici on le voit c'est une petite vidéo
que je vous montre est un petit peu plus
tard et ce qui est intéressant et bien
c'est le commentaire voir chez l'avant
dernier nous donne nous fait une vidéo
pour nous montrer comment nous laver les
mains pour ne pas gaspiller dos vous le
voyez le commentaire derrière est un peu
ironique bientôt nous dira comment dîner
sans allumer la lumière la publication
elle a quand même recueilli vous le
voyez pas loin de
647 like ça c'était en anglais a été
également partager ici en français par
ce conte où elle a été largement plus
commenté et partagez vous le voyez
plusieurs milliers de like le problème
est bien et bien c'est que c'est d'abord
je vais d'abord vous montrer la petite
vidéo en question pour que vous n'ayez
pas à me croire sur parole on voit
effectivement donc un jouet mais ici
c'est un peu anecdotique mais on voit
donc effectivement hollande derrière qui
se lave les mains c'est palpitant vous
me direz mon cher raphaël le problème
est bien c'est que c'est faux et pour
s'en rendre compte et bien comme souvent
info ou intox et de manière générale
quand on veut vérifier la crédibilité
d'une information il suffit de faire une
recherche d'image inversé on a pris donc
cette vidéo et on a donc fait une
recherche d'image inversée et en tombant
donc sur cette recherche d'image
inversée on est donc tombée si je me
permets de la retrouver il me semble que
je n'arrive pas à la retrouver
voilà c'est bon j'ai réussi mon cher
raphaël on retombe donc sur ce compte
youtube de la commission européenne l'a
doute est issu
donc cette vidéo est là où c'est
intéressant et bien c'est que la vidéo
originale que je vais vous montrer vous
allez le voir à la télé les gens armand
différente de celle que vous avez pu
voir vous voyez il ya tout un bandeau
qu'on aperçoit en haut de la vidéo qui a
donc été tronquée dans la vidéo que je
vous ai montré là vous voyez il a donné
des consignes comment bien se laver les
mains à travers les doigts etc et pour
cause est bien parce que cette vidéo en
fait elle date de la pandémie de kovy d
ursula von der leyen ce le jeu se
lançait à l'époque un challenge lancé
par l'om ait cessé d'ailleurs précisé un
peu plus loin sur la vidéo et bien c'est
le safe and challenge vous le voyez le
oms qui là encore là vous voyez ici sur
ce twitt que j'ai pris pour vous en
exemple qui date de janvier 2001 ce safe
and challenge pour et bien diffusée face
à la pandémie de covin les baies moyen
de se laver les mains vous le voyez donc
et bien que 7,7 cette vidéo a donc été
raccourcie détourné tronquée et que son
but était bien c'était peut-être de
faire de l'humour ou en tout cas plus
probablement et bien deux d'induire en
erreur
vous voulez nous parler le concerne
cette fois le ministre allemand de la
santé oui absolument et là c'est
peut-être un petit peu plus sérieux je
vous laisse en juger sa part tout
d'abord de ce tweet là encore vous
l'apercevez avec un extrait de cette
vidéo que je vous montrerai un petit peu
plus tard que dit le commentaire ici
vous voyez l'auteur bac est donc le nom
du ministre allemand de la santé nous
empêcherons la pandémie de prendre fin
et elle le que le tweet est bien de dire
quelqu'un de sens s'attendait sans doute
pas à ce que cette déclaration
révélatrice hu a enregistré
sous-entendus et bien vous l'avez
compris que c'est une déclaration qui a
été est bien faite sous le sceau du
secret la vidéo elle je vais vous la
montre et elle est très courte elle fait
pareil là encore une quinzaine de
secondes et on voit donc effectivement à
le ministre allemand de la santé c'est
bien lui s'est exprimé dans une vidéo
qui est donc un petit peu zoom et qu'on
pourrait dire peut-être monter avec des
propos des propos que je vous hais mais
ici en verbatim et le jeu vous les lits
si cela continue nous allons devoir nous
allons nous devons continuer ainsi nous
ne pouvons pas nous arrêter nous ne
pouvons pas dire maintenant nous allons
arrêter avec omicron au micro ne mettra
pas fin à la pandémie ce que nous
essayons d'empêcher sous-entendus et
bien c'est le propos de ces tweets qui
sont ouvertement un complotiste est bien
c'est de dire que les gouvernements
n'ont pas intérêt là encore à mettre fin
à la andy goode raphaël problème antoine
cet extrait est trompeur évidemment il a
encore eh bien il suffit de faire une
simple recherche d'image inversée pour
s'en rendre compte et or on tombe là
encore sur la vidéo originale et elle
est issue là encore d'une chaîne youtube
que vous voyez juste ici il s'agit
effectivement du ministre allemand de la
santé car l'auteur barre qu'il s'est
pris mais il s'est exprimé en euros en
revanche c'était le 14 janvier 2022 il
était devant le bundesrat c'est
l'équivalent notre sénat nous c'est une
assemblée en allemagne qui ressemble qui
rassemble les représentants des länder
allemands la vidéo elle vous le voyez
elle fait plus de quarante deux minutes
vous le voyez juste ici et je j'ai
retrouvé pour vous un l'extrait que j'ai
donc j'ai fait une capture d'écran ici à
peu près à 32 minutes et je retrouvais
pour vous l'extrait en intégralité vous
doutez bien que ce n'est pas ça n'a rien
à voir avec ceux le court verbatim que
je vous ai lu on retrouve ici la phrase
que je vous ai lu un petit peu plus tôt
mikron ne mettra pas fin à la pandémie
ce que nous essayons d'empêcher trois
petits points c'est là que la vidéo a
été coupée mais si c'est effectivement
cas les non-vaccinés seraient tous
infectés par omicron c'est aussi une
pensée parfois avancé etc je vous laisse
vous mêmes juges de ces deux ses propos
en résumé et bien ces propos et bien
c'était pour mettre en avant une
politique en faveur de la lutte contre
la pandémie tco vite vous l'avez encore
compris donc là encore on a le même
exemple une vidéo qui a été tronquée
raccourci voir monter là encore une fois
c'est pourrait bien induire en erreur et
là les comptes qui émettent ces
informations vous l'avez compris et bien
sont ouvertement anti vaccins et
complotistes à merci antoine info ou
intox d'antoine fenaux c'est terminé on
se retrouve nous dans trois minutes pour
un nouveau journal
[Musique]